hi everybody I'm Jonathan Johnson today
I got another tactical challenge for you
so when you see the image on your screen
go ahead pause your video and see if you
can solve it in this position it is
black to move this is a game that I
played against stock to shape so I was
playing against a computer I had the
white pieces here I'm already down upon
and my position is worse but here the
computer found a nice little tactic in
this position I was surprised when the
computer played Knight to d4 a very nice
little tactic forking the Queen and the
bishop and the first point is if I take
back on d4 black plays Queen d4 forking
the king and the rook so after my King
moves
I lose my rook also if on the other hand
I play as I did in the game Queen to d1
now black just takes on f3 and when I
take back the computer takes on d3 now
black is up two pawns my C pawn is weak
and my position is slowly falling apart
a nice little tactic by the silicon
monster thank you everybody for watching
I'm thinking grats to everybody that was
able to get this one right as always hit
like share subscribe and we'll see you
next week for another tactical challenge